what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I'm John Humphrey it's the end
of the year the biggest trailer we
covered was Avengers endgame so figured
why not end the year but learning about
some small details we missed hopeful
avengers endgame trailer if you're not
see a reaction do it go check it out
right now there's a sketch that plays
right before it that seems like most
people quite enjoyed it's our most liked
video of the whole year we also did a
breakdown video of it and such so really
appreciate it before we do that we must
say thank you to all who have followed
us on patreon over there we do weekly
Q&A as well as TV show reaction watch
along for several shows if you're
already complete but right now we are
currently covering attack on side and
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia Riverdale and Gotham and
supernatural and John also does music
video coverage so yeah yeah yeah Eddie
here this is from looper love this
channel man let's get to it let's see
what we missed I missed them all the
speculation Avengers movie has finally
arrived but one thing the trailer
reveals the title for the feature as
Avengers end game confirming previously
leaked to have indicating that might be
the case there's a world of mystery to
this footage showing us our first
official glimpse of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe post statuses decimation you've
already watched to read watch
let's break down some of the small
details you might have missed in the
trailer for Avengers and game is now
retired to his quiet life as a big
purple space fun we did not miss this
excellently see this well time frame
join the movies ending sequence of oh we
are dizzy gold it's comic book series
for the story the Scarecrow is a
striking image from the final issue in
the comic the Scarecrow appears to be
fastest only company when the heroes
come upon its they regard it as an empty
shell of what was which may imply some
interesting to install for the final
showdown between the Avengers and foes
as for Fellowes himself he's only seen
briefly in the trailer running his hand
over some plant life with his burnt
after sitting out the events of infinity
war Jeremy Renner's Clint Barton has
returned to the fourth Avengers
adventure and sort of thing is very
different about him he's gonna get a new
star is why our fellow change seems so
much shocked to say
Ruba something spoil their Japanese box
and sheds his old identity
and maybe even a little bit of his
morality when his entire family
presumably gets just that at the end of
infinity war we didn't even know they
weren't decimated this is my perfect
opportunity obviously read some cash
around it's the house is coming via the
newest vessel of the guardians of the
galaxy the Bennett ah which took the
place of the Milano after its
destruction and guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 of course not all is as bleak as
it first appears but one Tony does not
seem to be alone on this side of dudes
trip across the universe it looks like
that below is
with him hitching a ride after her ship
was destroyed during her showdown the
Pharos on tighter her blue fingers can
be seen on someone's shoulder probably
Tony's considering she's more robot than
Mario being at this point
thanks to thanasis tinkering it's
possible that the lack of oxygen and
food on the ship this is as big a deal
to her as it is to Tony for months and
months rumors have swirled about the
Avengers going back in time to undo the
destruction fallows has caused that's
why he shaped by the expected occasion
that the production was rebuilding sets
from older movies it's hard to think of
any other reason why cap would be
looking down at a photo of a Peggy of
such significance unless he was about to
go and find her for some reason other
said leaks have indicated that the movie
may have built a new set of account
Levi's the boots camp in Captain America
the First Avenger where a pre super
serum Steve Rogers first proved it were
the base located in New Jersey was also
visited in the modern era in Captain
America the Winter Soldier and more
importantly it was destroyed so if the
movie is taking us to come Lehigh as the
leaf suggests then it's probably not
going to be in the present day well I
would explain cap going back to his
outfit from the Winter Soldier sort of
like when Star Trek characters have to
go back in time and try their best to
blend in so as to not screw up the
timestream
yep far I believed in your mystic
moments for the Avengers endgame trailer
revealed during the sequence of surprise
welcome to the party monitor smoking
around Avengers HQ they get a video
message to Manta man who seems to be at
the gates of the facility that's
exciting the Newark what's more exciting
as a gear that stopped what with him
last time we saw Ant Man son found it
have been turned into a makeshift
laboratory kitted out with a portal to
the quantum realm in the post-credits
sequence of ant-man and the wasp Scott
entered the quantum realm and appeared
to be stuck there with his partners
being just it before they could pull it
back Scott sure that's doomed so what
gives
right before Scott jumped into the
quantum ground
this warning from the original wasp and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you
used a vortex to exit the ground
depositing himself in the future and now
he's brought the time travel tech to
Avengers HQ he would have thought
ant-man will be so important when it
came time to save the world probably
this guy mean a lot of us didn't care
[Music]
it's a scarecrow what no we've seen
Jeremy Jones's video oh yeah about how
we didn't catch everything from yeah all
the source material catch that that was
a scarecrow gosh
John's what's wrong with you what gives
man did you pick the wrong word again
yeah oh yeah we saw some other video
before week watch the end game trade
yeah that pointed out that you do see
the Scarecrow at the end of infinity war
in the corner I had read the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book so I was like whoo
yeah well I do and you know and there
was some jackass as an art video who
were like this not a scarecrow
yeah yes what what oh ma Jean exactly
what the Scarecrow what that's my
biggest point of trivia pride when it
comes to this whole end game that's
knowing what the Scarecrow yeah a lot of
this is covered in the Avengers
breakdown video already it shouts out to
Andrew is anything we didn't catch each
certainly ya know especially with like
Ronan and everything yeah he killed his
family definitely I would love that
twist at the end when everybody comes
back and his family doesn't he's like
maybe it doesn't work I want to be like
that episode of Family Guy when quagmire
discovers porn they've got like
thousands literally millions of naked
pictures on the internet what they're
like oh your family was decimated what I
mean decimated we're half the world
those was snapped into non-existence
yeah yeah I didn't just bury their
bodies in the in the farm
yeah they weren't holding me back for my
real ambition like seriously and
convenien when trying to fight super
villains of the a verse where I was at
this pressure of trying get back to my
family
so I just harmed them it stands to
reason that nebula is on that ship with
Tony because what they're saying about
Captain America's Basin everything
because that that's a great point though
of allottees looking at that photo of
Peggy and why I've always just
associated Captain America as someone
who is missing or mourning over Peggy
Carter I actually read into that and
we've talked plenty of times on this
channel about how there's most likely
the time travel scenario with those
leaked photos and everything like that
and and everything they're pointing out
here that the two biggest takeaways I
got from this video specifically were
direct references to Captain America's
old suit the fact that he is clean shame
they might might explain more why he's
actually shave yeah yeah I don't know I
don't know I never put that together
like oh yeah it's time travel yeah
actually yeah I was very clever in his
subtle way yeah there's a purpose I was
so caught up on him not having a beard
anymore that I forgot to ask myself
oh yeah he's time-traveling that's
probably why he doesn't have a beard yet
he heard that Machine Gun Kelly track he
was like ah weird weird beard but the
ant van as well that little nugget of a
detail Michelle Pfeiffer's saying don't
get stuck and sucked into a time vortex
and that he's probably bringing that
with them and I'm like oh yeah it was
all laid out for us and for summary I
like of course I'm everyone notices Ant
Man in the trailer but I didn't really
pay attention to did to the van and at
first it's very easy just be like well
and and and I wondered what similar this
just makes me curious what the time
vortex rules are and how that's gonna
factor in cuz they said you know
something in here about him maybe using
one to do like transport into the future
or something like that and it seemed
like he was in the present you know at
that time well yeah because when the
when the decimation happened he was he
was stuck in the quantum realm yeah
then he's shown maybe he's just
time-traveled to a few days wherever
like cuz I I imagine endgame I don't
know is gonna pick up immediately after
or it's gonna pick up like a few weeks
after or five years we've grieved for
everybody yeah moved on it would make
sense that it's been a long time though
at least a year would an appropriate
yeah this is a fun video thank you so
much looper for putting this together
you guys can subscribe to looper
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us out on
patreon got plenty of goodies happy
freaking New Year to you sons of
bastards
you